[Musique]
michel david michels et roger bonsoir
chantal on règle un petit souci
technique la voix est là dans quelques
secondes cette histoire par bonsoir dos
à cette histoire par et relancés
devraient agir hier dévoilement de la
statue de monsieur parizeau à québec
donc il ya des invités dont monsieur
bouchard qui se fait questionner
etes-vous toujours souverainisme son
chat croyez-vous toujours en ce rêve va
sur un t il répond oui ce rêve doit
rester vivant est vivant mais là il va
pas dans les modalités pourront pas
d'armé sur le fond de la chose inouïe je
crois que ça reste la meilleure chose
pour le québec la souveraineté alors on
pose la question à monsieur legault
ce matin à l'assemblée nationale joue
fait entendre
j'espère que chantal va en temps mais en
tout cas je vous fais entendre la
réponse de monsieur legault êtes vous
encore souverainisme sur le groupe
on est un parti nationaliste à
l'intérieur du canada nationale et ça
veut dire quoi en trop protégé pour une
fois le français qui renoncent à votre
on a entendu un journal et savez vous
renoncez à votre rêve monsieur legault
michel david vous écriviez ce matin que
monsieur legault dans une entrevue qui a
été publiée quelques années
on donnait l'impression qu'il n'avait
pas renoncé à ses rêves la banque s'est
relancé où vous en êtes maintenant oui
mais d'abord cette entrevue là que j'ai
pris dans l'acte l'action nationale
a pas vraiment été au repos eu lieu a eu
lieu mais monsieur legault a jamais dit
des choses comme celles là là je pense
pas qu'il faut se baser là dessus
maintenant pour ce qui est de ce que
pense monsieur legault si vous me
demandez une opinion je pense qu'il est
du même avis que monsieur bouchard comme
comme dans beaucoup de choses
et surtout de la façon dont ils
expriment ces choses on est un parti
nationaliste c'est vrai ce sont partis
ce nationalisme ça veut pas dire que lui
d'accord avec tout ce que son parti et
il sait très bien qu'à l'intérieur de
son parti il y aura grosso modo la
moitié du souverainiste la moitié de
fédéralistes alors à moins qu'on arrive
dans un grand jeu là qui va la forcer à
une prendre à prendre une décision
monsieur legault va continuer à marcher
sur la ligne film notre nationalisme qui
débouche sur la souveraineté et l'autre
sur le fédéralisme plus ou moins
renouvelé mais le fond de sa pensée
une seule la connaît mais je soupçonne
qu'elle ressemble beaucoup à celle de
monsieur bouchard michel chelsea auger
bonsoir chantal
vous êtes là merci michel serrault j'ai
ouï sa réponse n'est pas étonnant qu'ils
n'allaient pas dire aujourd'hui mais ça
y est je fonce vers la souveraineté mais
mais néanmoins il s'intéresse à l'un
c'est ça y est je veux faire entendre
d'autres shows tout à l'heure mais
d'abord sur sa réponse michel
d'abord il pouvait pas dire autre chose
le jour où il se déclarait sur red bull
le cédant qu'aux actionnaires québec
bien tombé puis deux parties n'existe
plus et il n'est plus premier ministre
je suis pas capable de sonder les reins
et les coeurs dessus une gauche pascal
mais il a choisi d'aller de quitter le
parti québécois être fond d'un autre
parti parce qu'ils voulaient d'un doublé
de poids et c'est je pense une
considération qui plus importante pour
lui que la souveraineté d'autant que
donc là soit il sortira jamais du
paysage politique québécois parti
québécois pour avoir des problèmes mais
la soul intéressant et ça me rend folle
mais il n'y a pas de
surprendre le monde monsieur legault kz1
soumaya pas d'acceptabilité ca ca qui
s'était il n'y a pas de débat pas de
conditions gagnantes
pions balle on ne servira pour faire un
référendum parce qu'ottawa dit non à la
réunification familiale il ya quelque
chose qui marche et ta que ce quelque
chose le vauban à qui je pense pas que
monsieur legault va sortir de là deux
son but il sur cette question là voilà
il joue l'équilibriste là dessus parce
qu y at-il vraiment besoin de renier si
tenté qu'il croit encore que c'est la
meilleure solution pour le québec ça est
par ailleurs être pragmatique les deux
peuvent aller ensemble chantal ouais
mais la raison pour laquelle la
coalition haguenau québec ratissent
large c'est justement parce qu'il est
installé sur cette clôture le même chez
elle parle de singing des fois une ligne
fine si le corps de regarder il faut
faire un peu attention c'est pas cela
dit si monsieur legault veut avoir des
états d'âme dans ce sens là y'a pékin
des gens qui vont être très content ça
s'appelle le parti libéral du québec et
le parti québécois parce que ce serait
comme les sorties audio orateur
artificielle donne une grande bouffée
d'oxygène à l'eau et l'autre parce qu'on
retombe dans le débat où la question de
l'urne pour beaucoup d'électeurs cs
comprend une chance qui est un autre
référendum sur la souveraineté et vous
connaissez les résultats ces deux partis
là ont des chiffres qui en témoin mais
si je peux me permettre aux yankees
je pense que la question se pose pas
vraiment maintenant elle est largement
théorie ce que les gens se demandent si
si il y avait une situation qui
reproduisait un climat du genre de celui
de la praye lac meech et kg il y avait
une ouverture est ce que monsieur
legault profiterait d'ouverture ou s'ils
feraient comme monsieur bourassa qui
s'organiserait pour clark la fenêtre se
referme c'est ça la vraie question pour
le moment monsieur legault a absolument
aucune raison de chercher les problèmes
qui avaient considérable avec son
pare chocs en passant de l'école de
meech et la suite c'était pas parce que
on a perdu la chance de mettre dans la
constitution les pouvoirs du québec en
immigration c'était sur la
reconnaissance du caractère fondamental
du québec comme dans les autres
canadiens veulent pas accepter ce qu'est
le québec est la différence québécoise
mais très très franchement si ça avait
été juste on a échoué à la table
constitutionnel à merde dans la
constitution des pouvoirs l'immigration
je crois pas qu'à
95 c'était plus fondamental vous dit
chantal mid et d'ailleurs est d'ailleurs
monsieur bouchard serait peut-être
rester avec monsieur ma journée ici mais
je n'avais pas assez pour rappel le bloc
peut enfin bref on peut refaire
l'histoire mille fois mais michel david
touche michel sauget je vous donne la
parole michèle dawe et touche à cette
théorie quand même qui circulent depuis
plus c'est pas nouveau là mais on dit si
jamais il arrive un moment où il ya une
colère collective chez les chez les
québécois va-t-il lui traverser le
rubicon va-t-il lui et c'est ça la
question et ses cinq autres pour
certains c'est un soin pour d'autres
c'est une crainte michel la question
c'est est-ce que son parti va le suivre
s'il franchit le rubicon et comme il ya
une moitié de ce parti et pas les moins
ouvertement des indices il ya plusieurs
semaines
alors il ne peut pas aller là s'il est
tout seul de sa gamme et sont partis
pour cesser d'exister s'il fait ça il le
sait très bien il va cesser d'être
premier ministre du québec je pense
qu'il ya mieux être éliminé du québec
que de franchir le rubicon mais non
adaptés à michel que au moment où la
cause laxmi qui a échoué il y avait des
ministres d'un cabinet bourassa dont on
soupçonnait pas l'ombre d'un sentiment
nationaliste qu'ils étaient prêts à
partir en guerre et est accepté une
forme de souveraineté alors l'avenir
trop tard
l'avenir dure longtemps est-ce que je
suis apte à le souligner c'est que
l'échec de meech et quand même ressenti
ça sert c'est beaucoup de pouvoir vie
derrière si le québec avait eu ses
pouvoirs l'on serait serait notre
planète presque entre converse mais ce
que souligne chatel c'est que ces
conditions là sont pas facilement
réuni-es que 96 d'un côté seul un rejet
par la cour suprême est ce que un autre
rejet sur une autre loi sur les signes
religieux est-ce que ça ça serait
suffisant pour créer un bouillonnement
mais comme michel vous dire on ne sait
pas si tous assez lisse y aller je pense
que ou l'autre je me tais je me trompe
de michel vauzelle cher
on ne sait pas mais on sait par exemple
que le parti québécois ont vraiment
voulu essayer ça moi je demeure
convaincu que la charte des valeurs
étaient puis le gouverneur de l'adamaoua
nos potes mardi d'avis juridiques au
ministère des sports si vous espériez
devant la cour suprême si adopter cette
loi là en espérant que bouillet demain
reviendrai mais non
on fait des théories sur la comète très
bien je vais vous faire entendre parce
que michel ces objets vous avez il ya
une partie qui le suivrait pas vous
allez l'entendre il ya effectivement des
députés et là ça va vous faire penser à
un film
les extraits qu'on va vous vous
présenter mais on vous les présente ses
des ministres du gouvernement de la cac
oui il faut mettre notre poing sur la
table et klami ce qu'on doit réclamer
qu'on peut très bien le faire à
l'intérieur du canada par contre faut
pas se mettre à presque un nationalisme
gênés ou un nationalisme timide parce
qu'on n'en fera pas de guerre il faut
s'assumer je pense qu'on peut très bien
faire à l'intérieur du canada ont fait
partie du canada anglais et du canada
français ensemble et notre objectif
c'est de faire avancer le québec pour
l'instant on fait partie du canada il
n'y a pas d'enjeu ne s'est pas d'enjeu
de séparer nous sommes un parti national
moi j'aime bien le canada on est au
québec on va respecter le québec mais
dans un canada ce que vous payez le
canada j'adore le canada je voyage au
canada
alors bon
ils vont des gens que dit un québec fort
dans un canada uni
alors si si le l'équilibriste parce que
la caq raciste elle dans un large que
forcément
tour de table rapide il faut qu'elles
attisent les deux côtés et michel oui
bien entendu mais oui écoutez si si
monsieur legault et sérieux paix qui dit
que la survie du québec français est en
jeu à un moment donné le il va falloir
qu'ils tirent les conclusions si aucune
concession qui est fait où ils
s'écrasent complètement ce que j'ai de
la difficulté à imaginer où il est forcé
de foncer en avance si non ce qui nous
raconte c'est de la bouillie vos
messages je
ne suis pas michel thoury askus on est
on est où le monsieur legault pour une
demande de rapatriement de pouvoirs sur
la grille vinification familiale c'est
la louisianisation
peut-être que c'est parce qu'on est
proche de l'élection qui fait ça observé
excusez moi l'homme et si c'était si
elle porte par axa le déclin du français
de ce poids réveillère il y aurait pas
d'affairé là dessus au 44e mois de
mordad 48 mois il ne le fait plus tôt il
ya eu une une urgence alors est-ce que
l'urgence est électoral actuellement ou
si elle est réelle je pense que quand je
vois le cas l'abri
mais ce que michèle dawe est dit
chanteuse sait que sa rhétorique fait en
sorte que forcément il pose la question
mais vous faites quoi devant un nom
revenez vous souffrez nice n'est fait
comment jean chrétien disait ça quand on
s'est peinturé dans un coin en marche la
peinture je ne crois pas que c'était le
souhait de françois le goût de nous
faire assister aux professions de foi de
tous bords y compris l'amour des voyages
au canada qu'on a vu aujourd'hui c'est
pas seul clan certainement beaucoup
parce que dans le moment les seuls qui
ont des problèmes avec sa déclaration et
qui ont l'air un peu de deux pointures
ont perdu leur tête c'est les membres de
son conseil des ministres
toutes une stratégie on va arriver
bien oui avec un parti
comme ça je le disais tout c'est parti
entre autres les questions à monsieur
legault oui du débat sur la langue mais
hier monsieur bouchard qui a dit moi
j'ai fondamentalement enfin au profond
de moi je crois encore mais est un gros
mais le pq ça va vraiment pas bien je
vous dis ça parce que je vous présente
un extrait d'une entrevue que je vais
présenter demain une longue entrevue que
monsieur bouchard il préside les
commémorations du centième anniversaire
de rené lévesque ce tout au long de
l'année je les rencontrais cette
occasion là et on a parlé de politique
de souveraineté et du pq un petit
extrait
l'idée il le projet
c'est un rêve
c'était également je pense une nécessité
politique quand on regarde l'histoire du
québec on peut pas se laisser dépouiller
comme moi ça se passe présentement soit
acculé dans le coin langue française
menacée non il faut garder l'idée il
faut garder la détermination mais comme
un chat on ne sait pas quelle forme ça
va prendre trois elles savent
transformer comment
peut-être ou peut-être pas un projet sur
vos n'échappe à la tierce comme on dit
avec j'avais je me suis certain qu'il ya
quelque chose qui me des mots au
printemps et qui va s'exprimer d'une
façon jean audin a dit policiers
québécois
donc moi je me vois désespéré à l'idée
que parce que nous avons bien
même s'il ne sera que nous ayons fait
entre nous il m'invite pas kabyle et non
plus oui bon pas farouche avaient cessé
ce beau monde y en a des gens que j'ai
beaucoup de respect puis ci ayant du
mérite mais disons que ya quelque chose
qui ne clique pas dans le débat
politique il ya quelque chose comme un
supplice ou si on a mal pour qui noël
tant qu'ils restent là mais on peut
imaginer que peut-on imaginer que
un parti
2022 en octobre offert une campagne
électorale où ils vont promettre de
faire j'ai été élu
pour vous c'est de la folie pour la
folie mais c'est un manque de c'est un
défaut que rené lévesque n'avait pas un
manque de réalisme
un manque de réalisme que de promettre
un référendum sur le sur la souveraineté
de la part du parti québécois monsieur
bouchard qui dit le rêve on peut parler
tant il aurait pu vous l'avez dit michel
sogeta leur pipe bomb chez david
chanteuse est d'accord avec ça
évidemment cette idée là une personne
qui est sérieux qui comprend le débat
politique dit prétend que ça va mourir
mais actuellement propose aux québécois
un référendum il dit le pq garde mérite
pas d'aller bien comme dit tour de table
sur ce qu'on vient d'entendre michel
davy bah écoutez monsieur bouchard a
toujours pensé soeur du pq je pense ça
jamais vraiment cliqué entre monsieur
bouchard le pq ça a été l'histoire de
son règne ça a été une histoire d'une
chicane intérieur au sein du pq alors
monsieur bouchard dit tout haut ce
qu'ils pensaient tout bois à l'école et
bien honnêtement je pense qu'il a raison
j'ai peur que les souverainistes doivent
se trouver un autre véhicule après la
prochaine élection ça me paraît dingue
mais que la souveraineté d'homère une
idée vivante c'est clair et je pense
même qu un gouvernement comme celui de
monsieur legault a tout intérêt à ce que
cette cette idée le train dans le
paysage parce que si le il n'y a plus
aucun malaise qui est ressenti à
l'extérieur du québec bah pourquoi ce
qu'on va se préoccuperait de ces
éternels chaleur michel c
le pq vignes à cause de son del radical
qui la force à bête dans son programme à
chaque élection on va faire un rapide
essor
quel est le radical du pq qui 300 et
c'est ça qui va le conduire peut-être
même de cette élection si elle à la
disparition même s'ils ont juré de le
mans un moment donné le manque de
réalisme non pas le suggère il y avait m
et si on veut que ce parti doit exister
en tant que mouvement existe en soyons
là il ya un autre parti
ou blix a essaimé cette ville dont cap
en train de mourir mais si on veut que
ça devienne une force politique capable
de gagner il va falloir faire autre
chose que de dire
on va prouver qu'on est une reine si ça
marche chantal bon on s'entend je pense
tous sur la même chose à part le
programme actuel du parti québécois
faire un troisième référendum dans les
quatre prochaines années ceci est lié
kaas pons habilité total c'est à dire si
tu es l'option 3 fois
le nom serait probablement
sans que la dernière fois mais la phrase
qui voit qu'au lycée quand lucien
bouchard quand même été premier ministre
et élu majoritaire ce qui est arrivé à
personne après lui au parti québécois
qui dit le parti québécois méritent pas
de bien à lui
et encore du tirant d'eau du sien
bouchard et
jeu le message c'est vraiment
ça soit plus le parti québécois et je
vous fais en fer qui m'amène à mon
dernier extrait paul st pierre plamondon
aujourd'hui à qui on a demandé
d'abord est ce que vous croyez monsieur
legault et soudainement il amène son
convient d'avoir nous pendant 15 minutes
on lui demande ce qu'ils devraient
l'être et là vous allez voir un moment
quand même étonnant il est battu c'est
comme s'ils comprenaient pas pourquoi
monsieur legault
n'enfourche est pas le cheval la
souveraineté galopeurs n'écoute
je sais pas
à force de répéter aux québécois qu'ils
ne sont pas bons qu'ils ne sont pas
capables à force d'être dans le
pessimisme un moment donné oui c'est un
impact c'est ce que je demande à
françois legault d'arrêter de faire
d'arrêter de dire aux gens qu'ils sont
pas bons
on est capable d'être un pays qui on n'a
pas le choix si on veut pérennité legus
tic et culturels
il y avait beaucoup d'émotion à québec
aujourd'hui on le voit bon fin de
session vous allez me dire vous avez
connu ça chantal tour de table il était
comme s'ils étaient sonnés par touchant
légèrement des arsenaux et mieux se
préparer
ça va ça va être encore plus fraudées ou
que ce point de presse le d'autre part
je pense que beaucoup de choses que
beaucoup de gens peuvent reprocher à
françois le goût mais l'impression
qu'ils viennent passer 90 aux québécois
qui sont pas bons peut-être pas
tellement partagiez à l'extérieur du
parti québécois et avec la dernière fin
de semaine encore mois michel st
un des problèmes du pq c'est justement
que quelqu'un comme moi un chef
maintenant
et ça c'est une belle chose l'autre
c'est que
le pq est plus propriétaire de cette
idée non il n'est plus le seul véhicule
et les gens se peut un visage à sima qui
lie à un autre véhicule que le pq et le
jour où ils voudront s'en servir pour
faire ça si jamais une chose alors
c'est moi qu'on peut c'est michel d vite
d'abord monsieur saint-pierre pas d'un
monde on n'a pas assisté au congrès de
la cac en fin de semaine donnée à
pasticher legault a pas arrêté de nous
dire comment ce qu'on était bon qu'on
peut être fier de ce qu'ont fait plus
bon maintenant je comprends son désarroi
ils s'envoient direct dans le mur il le
sait on a vu son honneur du chevreuil le
qui voit la voiture est arrivée un peu
mais il faut dire que avant la course au
leadership
tous les candidats sauf peut-être
enfin même je sais pas de même selon
elle il ya personne qui pensait là qu'il
fallait se précipiter dans un référendum
mais ils se sont rendu compte que c'est
ce que les militants voulaient entendre
ils savent bien qu'ils pouvaient pas
gagner une élection là dessus mais pour
être chef ses tresses me fallait passer
par là et là ils sont pris avec cette
stratégie low qui est suicidaire de
toute évidence et monsieur c'est saint
pierre prémont dont vous êtes obligé de
vivre avec ça jusqu'à la fin parce que
là il peut plus changer d'idée c'est ça
très bien il reste presque plus de temps
simplement pour dire aux gens que les
les cartes demande pour le parti
conservateur c'est demain minuit chantal
certaine aujourd'hui 500 melman donc ça
voudrait dire que certains en ont vendu
beaucoup chantal bon 500000 mans moi
aussi j'ai entendu ce sa frappe
l'imagination
qui sont vendus beaucoup c'est
probablement vrai le cheval nommé pierre
poilievre entendons-nous ce qui concerne
où on a vendu les cartes parce qu'au
québec s'attend 7800 membres à 100 par
circonscription et on bat complètement
la saskatchewan avec cent mille membres
à cause de résultats pondérer
on le sent repos
qui vend du coin avant le vote mais de
tout et la dernière fois sur 266
quelques 1000 membres il y en a cent
mille qui ont pas voté
très bien on va en reparler merci
beaucoup très intéressant merci michel
michel et shot on va vous changer de
prénom merci beaucoup le savent très
bien tout d'abord
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit